okay and we are live welcome to the iron
Lords podcast episode number 26 and it's
another glorious Sunday and we are back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guests so
we're gonna get right into it I want to
introduce a Lord whose content I've had
the pleasure of coming across through
some mutual friends Lawrence Eric
Jackson Santo Berg and be money this is
a law that always provides brutally
honest feedback from a multi-platform
perspective and it's fearless and
calling out issues he feels on just in
these gaming streets similar to the ILP
this law provides a platform where
different opinions are encouraged and
true gamers can discuss what's most
important enjoying these great games
introducing the creator and host of the
basement radio arcade podcast the
hardcore gamer for the people and the
only man who delivers the truth 4k 60
frames per second podcast every
Wednesday night Bob love rap how we
doing sir gentlemen good afternoon hey I
love that intro by the way today I'm
doing well just ready talk some
videogames with you with you gentlemen
and again you know thank you for having
me on I definitely appreciate it and you
know it's always good to connect with
other gamers who just have a general
appreciation for gaming and you know
don't get caught up on all the the
console war stuff and fanboy stuff so
like I said I'm really excited to be on
so thank you again gentlemen absolutely
a pleasure to absolutely have it of
course we have the usual suspects at the
round table our co-hosts with the Co
most might be missing in action today so
hopefully we'll get him a little later
you had a little rough work schedule so
if we can get them in but um I want to
introduce the rest of the Lords and of
course we have our most technical game
Lord the solo gamer who lives for the
single-player experience semi offline
ps4 pro al
Menotti Babu Lord sovereign are we doing
sir
fantastic man doing good nice and low
rested no no boxing or UFC to keep me up
last night
so you got there's no hangovers no
Jake's the XS game mmm the Lord who was
a man of his conviction experience and
of course um needle head and we are
spreading you that gaming realness from
the IOP telling you not what you want to
hear but what you need so before we get
started and what the Lord's are playing
this week I want to first start off with
Lord rap and his video game system
history
I wanna get into that and I also want to
ask them also just the early history of
the of the great brat podcast and how it
started so let's start with you your
video game systems and how you got
starting this whole game
culture oh man I've been doing this a
long time I'm probably been gaming about
35 years now Oh talk that og talk talk
about yes one of the reasons why I'm so
passionate about gaming is because I
started gaming at a very early age on
the Atari 2600 ColecoVision of
television I mean oh oh
yep and and one of the reasons why I
chose arcade and the title for braaap is
because that's where you used to go when
you were young used to go to the arcades
used to grow that's where the new
releases came out that's where you went
to go play there were arcades everywhere
every mall had an arcade and there was
lines you have to put your quarters down
that's where I first played Street
Fighter so yeah I've been doing this a
long time and I remember when there was
no gaming industry when he came out and
literally destroyed the gaming industry
people don't know that I remember buying
Atari cartridges and I'd lots of fifty
cents a pop yeah and so you know I've
lived that I mean I saw and that's a lot
of your dose that's why when Nintendo
came out with the NES it was all the
Nintendo Entertainment System and why
they included Rob because they they
wanted to position the console as I like
like as a toy basically mm-hm
you know and and not as a gaming console
because of what happened here in North
America so from there I you know I had
you know once the NES dropped I had that
a Sega Master System nice yeah I was I
pretty much have been on 50 console or
most of my you ever took the plunge in
Neo Geo cuz I took the plunge in that
early no I never did that Neo Geo was a
little bit out of my price range at the
time got really out of here
[Music]
yeah I had a friend who had one but you
know I turbo graphics 16 I mean the
Genesis the SNES I mean you know I mean
those were I mean those were the days I
mean for me that was such a you know and
and and I've had a if you've been doing
this a long time we have this unique
experience where were you seeing gaming
you talk about a change a revolution in
gaming I mean I was there when we went
from 2d to 3d
we went from cartridge system cartridge
game cartridge to CD disc I mean that
those were that was game changer that
was a changer that's and that's you know
I feel lucky that I've got to experience
some of those things from you know
growing up you know playing games for
the last 35 years you know in an hour
we're seeing some technological advances
with you know online and and VR now but
yeah that's why I'm passionate that's
why I don't understand the whole you
know not to get on my soapbox but the
whole console war stuff because it's
stupid you know we're all gamers would
all love gaming and I understand
absolutely
Haidee well you know it gets into we we
always have to feel that we have to take
a side in things no matter what and it's
it's it's in our nature so I can
understand why a lot of guys would say
I'm Sony or ominous
and sometimes it's economics when you go
to the store you pick up a game system
some people don't have the choice to go
in and pick up both so they pick one any
bet on that horse heavy and when that
horse is in the lead a little bit you
know they charity want to raise the paw
good choice so I feel that but sometimes
it crosses the line into weirdism you
feel that you have to put down somebody
else's choice to make somebody else feel
bad about their choice and boost your
choice no you just made a choice you
just bet on the horse and if your horse
when your horse win but remember there's
always another race and maybe your horse
will lose that time but they haven't
been around long enough to understand
that fact you know because a lot of
people like you said you you bet on
Atari I bet on Atari
I was playing pitfall when attareekh a
win um he came out and destroyed my
world exploded mob rapid talk and I'm
like no I remember that Cliquot like I
was my first one year I was a Nintendo
head he was a Sega Master System said
you know we didn't bump heads we were
just like oh you got that game over
we don't have gaming back then was
different appeared to opposed to gaming
now gaming lines drawn in the sand I'll
kill you religious wars now I'm just
like I noticed it and it's strange that
they can't let that red versus blue go
yeah yeah it is strange it really is in
you know I I'm I'm lucky from the sense
that I have that perspective you know
that you know I saw the industry fail I
go back to a time where I will sit
before we move over the second part full
of crap what I realized though about
that error as much as I loved it I think
it also reinforced what something was an
arcade perfect because we know there's a
translation that you did I came home to
the home whether was the original NES or
math system or even the oldest systems
you know and then you you saw the Home
version versus the art
you didn't own our case but as things
progressed and got more powerful you
didn't start to see how close and it was
almost one-to-one you know relationship
as far as absolutely absolutely
attacking I remember that was when my
first and rich ratio stuff but enough
about me this is about Lord rap so we're
gonna get into also I want to know tell
us about the the evolution in the
creation of the basement radio arcade
about pocket how did that start so I was
actually um I was part of a podcast
prior to braaap you guys might be
familiar with the original next level
gaming podcast yes yeah so it was myself
Mike Mullis and wari work I'm following
he's a good guy in Twitter yeah he is
he's great he he's a guy and I have a
lot of respect for because he just um he
just loves gaming yes its though you
know if ands or buts about just loves
gaming and it's so passionate about it
just cuz he's one of those few that just
doesn't get caught up on all the the
console wars nonsense but we started
with them and then you know I just felt
like you know I I really enjoy you know
what Mike's doing it next level gaming
but I felt like you know what I because
of what I saw was going on in the
community and a lot of fanboy stuff I
was like you know gamers need a place
real gamers who are tired of the you
know the the console the console war
narrative and you know consistently
calling out media and complaining and
yadda yadda yadda they felt like gamers
needed a place where they can go and
just you know a safe place where they
can go kind of voice their opinions you
know and and it just talked about gaming
yes and that's why I came up with braaap
I was like you know what I'm gonna do a
podcast where people can come and just
listen to a variety of opinions and you
know and just kind of be a safe place
for people to say hey you know what I
don't like that company a B and C is
doing this what do you think oh you know
eggs yeah because at the end of the day
and I always say this like first and
foremost like guess where gamers but
where consumers to this hobby is not
cheap and this
are the killer I never understand why
people are reluctant to hold companies
accountable if a company doesn't puts a
good product out don't buy it don't
support it
yeah with your wallet yeah that is so
key absolutely I mean you know it's
people complaining about nonsense all
biased media no ei just released another
game is buggy it doesn't work I needs a
patch why don't you complain about that
they're charging you full price where
gaming doesn't work balanced aspect of
this is needed in this gaming community
and it's always a pleasure to support
guys like you that actually provide that
kind of Haven and that kind of content
so we're gonna get into what the Lord's
are playing this week so I'll start with
you Louis are um what are you what
you've been touching this week I know I
think I'm assuming helbling is one of
them how play this is all of it actually
I dropped everything to try to get
through hell-blade because I knew I was
gonna have a lot of time there today so
I try to do a little bit every day so
yeah and you got dropped everything to
play hell-blade this week okay cool
nice we go get into that I know you got
a lot to say about that though the other
that all right look King what's been on
the agenda this week
well fired up that super crazy beastie
uh by PowerPC that I purchased a ton of
Steam games I ordered my steam
controller so I'm waiting for that to
show up and I ordered my Nvidia shield
the next generation one to put
downstairs on my den because I want to
stream the games to do big screen mode
on the TV downstairs so I'm waiting for
that to show up before I really get
engaged into my PC world but I've been
playing a little bit of guilty pleasure
game Deadpool
you know every month I got this little
hustle where I get four to five free
games so I went to gamestop and I'm
getting my free games and so Deadpool
there for Xbox one I'm like thoroughly
enjoying this buggy game it's such a
manner that it should something's wrong
cuz I look around every time I'm playing
like I'm committing a sin it was such a
good game because it didn't take it so
seriously any little like buggy think it
even made jokes about the bugs I saw I
guess they were intentional or I guess
they couldn't take it out and they just
put a joke in there so like this game is
so much fun but that's what I've been
playing this all week nice it's still
it's August so for walking for me it's
it's hashtag kill the backlog no yes is
my thing though I
you know that's fastly approaching in
September so I'm just going through the
backlog right now and it's just been a
lot of telltale stuff um shout out the
Lord is EIC he's in the chat I mean a
lot of people I'm obviously a big
telltale guy with certain games story
narrative driven stuff and I like I said
last week I finished the Walking Dead
new frontier this week I started on the
wolf among us for the first time
actually that one fell from the cracks
nice and people are telling me like you
know telltale I have like a little
pantheon and for me surprisingly a game
that I put off I didn't think I was
gonna like which is my number one right
now is actually the tales from the
borderlands I don't know if you guys
play that yeah it is ha laughs I mean I
literally I'll never laugh out loud at a
video game almost throughout the entire
video game it's so well written and so
light and funny and the be honest I'm
not a hardcore borderlands guy so I
didn't think I was gonna even like the
universe to begin with so you know as
far as me playing a game that I really
didn't know much of you know the history
for them the ink you know can be
involved and emotionally connected I was
like I love this game so that's my
number one but a lot of people have been
telling me like more dizzy and I believe
on to other people that up
I talked to they were like listen a lot
anchor actually he was one of them
that actually said as well um wolf among
us that's the best one so I just started
I'm all about three or four episodes in
a man it's funny it's it's this Dalian
is funny it's good the fable or it's
really really good so I gotta see how it
in before I you know before I do my
personal telltale rankings so well you
have an enjoying that man and the other
thing I touched his arm shout-out to
inter LAN games they finally um drop the
long dark that was something that was in
TV program a long time it's a huge fan
of that game they've had some story
content to it and it's it's really good
y'all it's really good I mean if you
like that type of survival resource kind
of a deal it's not hard anything like
that it just about managing yourself in
the cold you know doing all these
different things out in the environments
food water you know in all that stuff
it's it's really cool they have some
story episodic stuff so that's what I've
been rocking and I'm going to jump into
these on polls so last week's poll
results are in and the people have
spoken
so the winner at 75% strong is the xbox
preview program bad for gaming is the
know it helps the program is slave labor
for broken games very stuff so pretty
one-sided I know you and obviously I
want to get a rap and when we think
about that as far as the preview program
when you guys with the people or you can
solo Brett we're yet with that you know
I'm okay with the preview program I
think it's it's gives people the
opportunity to play games with that they
may not otherwise be interested in you
know and
the only issue I have is when games are
still in preview and are still being
worked on and developers gonna start
charging like $60 I think this this
happened yeah and I have a little bit of
an issue with that because how are you
gonna charge someone a full retail price
for something that's mine you finished
yet yeah I was in Game Stop they have
for tonight in Game Stop for sale not
pre-order $60 for sale yeah that's a
little aggressive and and and the fine
print is like you really can't see
anywhere on the packaging that it says
preview in game and pre it's very small
so if you're going in that you're if you
don't not in the know you're gonna walk
in and you can purchase game thinking
the game is complete yep yeah and it's
not having and it's free next year yep I
mean I the idea itself
I'm okay with like but I'm not okay
again with my fear is like people gonna
go on by for night now at $60 other
developers gonna take notice because the
industry is very copycat yep and I think
like that could be a dangerous precedent
to set and I hope people don't support
that because I don't agree with that I
think it's great if you you want to open
up like a beta you want to get people in
a preview program you want to try out
your game you may be your small indie
dev you know you want people you wanna
get the gaming people's hands maybe a
little word of mouth but you can't go
out and charge people 60 dollars I'll be
mouth full would you go out and buy a
car that's that you know that's that's
uh that's a missing the truck about that
come in two months from now
this is so much fun but I see Microsoft
as preemptively striking at this with
that um the the creative collections yes
yes that collection creative program
thing that they're doing as a
counterbalance to the preview program
because it makes no sense to have to
type of the same programs in one eco
space but then when you look at them
they're diametrically opposed to their
philosophies so somebody one out and
Microsoft to get this program up and
running where developers don't have to
pay anything very it's small indie devs
could just jump up while they pay $20
and they can get their game up and
running and put on Microsoft marketplace
in Windows 10 and in the Microsoft eco
space with relative ease just yeah
Jonathan well fast mechanic Jackie's got
correctness he said actually fortnight
is not in the preview program which is
um I'm sorry I didn't realize that I
thought I thought it might have been but
it's not is what he's saying so pretty
much like I guess is what is an early
access I believe yes honestly I feel
like that your semantics it's the same
thing yeah we had to vote with the
entity at the end of the show so I'll
stay tuned for that we'll have something
cooking up on our Pete winner so let's
get into these topics so I want to start
off with our Lord song from a lot of
news going on recently some top-secret
stuff does ps4 Pro have the secret sauce
topic this is a kind of late-breaking
news I saw this for the first time last
night kind of late on WCC f Tech um they
posted an article talking about the
AMD's RX Vega
gpus which are set to launch next week
and basically talking about basically
talking about what kind of new features
they bring to the table
and something in particular that was
touched upon was the fact that they for
the first time they're gonna be
introducing something called rapid
packed math um and they the RPM for sure
yeah and essentially so basically this
feature what it does is it allows it
takes floating-point operations that
function in the 16-bit space and well
well floating-point operations that
function in the 32-bit space are allowed
to be broken down into two 16-bit
operations therefore making the
operation faster basically instead of
running one thirty two-bit operation
you'll be running to 16 bits upper
operations at the same time attaining
which allows you to basically attain
high fidelity higher frame rate and
higher graphical quality so it's it's
honestly it's something that when
implemented properly can be a game
changer for middle-of-the-road hardware
so cut you for a second and this is tech
this is AMD tech correct that that's
inside the yes right right so the talk
behind this was that I don't know if you
guys remember when we first started
talking about the Xbox one X um there
was talk coming out of somebody that yes
Xbox one xx6 teraflops of GPU power but
technically the ps4 Pro if we utilize
this this rapid pack math feature can
run operations simultaneously therefore
jumpin our GPU output to eight point
four meaning then we have more than Xbox
1x it was a there was a funny little
argument amongst the family boys the
funny thing is that it may not
necessarily be a lie
mean Oh some truth so mark Cerny ahead
of the launch of the pistols indicated
there were some future proofing things
that he put into the pro in order in
order to kind of stay ball something
like this with Microsoft coming out with
a more powerful console and just to kind
of follow the roadmap that Andy had in
place for the next couple of years
obviously both Microsoft and and and
Sony have AMD architecture in the
machines and so basically the ps4 Pro is
all set to go with this with this
software so the indication is well so
far they've indicated that far cry 5 and
Wolfenstein to the new Colossus will be
utilizing this this technology from the
ground up so what's interesting is that
the Xbox one acts at no point in time
have they indicated that they included
this in their SOC when they develop an
act though no one's come out and said
that they have or that they have in
right um but the assumption is that they
haven't considering how awful it means
the people are in the assumption is that
maybe they just thought it wasn't
necessary because the brute strength of
the system now the thing is with these
games coming out now particularly
Wolfenstein that we're gonna see in
October um if this is built from the
ground up utilizing this rpm technology
then we'll be able to get a pretty
decent look at what games how games are
gonna scale across both systems and if
they're gonna be a huge disparity
between what what's possible on the pro
and what's possible on x1x
so it's it's it's interesting because
again like you've mentioned the secret
sauce like in the beginning of the the
this generation with the one arm you
know with a resolution getting
everything that is talking about of of
the Xbox one X having the secret sauce
that they were going to be able to
unlock the esram and use it in
conjunction with the cloud or the ps4
and I mean to date none of that has come
to fruition and more than likely that's
not gonna
I guess we'll still see cloud technology
in the online component crackdown but
beyond that we don't know so it's going
to be interesting to see the type of
disparity between these two games when
you know when Wolfenstein launches in
October and then later on next year when
Far Cry comes on because it could it
could be it could be a selling point all
right for the ps4 Pro if the disparity
is not that large and they're able to
sell the pro at $100 difference then the
then the Xbox one by the time the next
one next by the time this comes out so
you know it's an interesting it's an
interesting little tidbit yeah about
this information I'll definitely want to
get the Lord's uh feedback when I start
with our Lord rap now this uh
information as far as rpm as releases
are the ps4 Pro well what do you feel
about this how do you think this is his
help or way you're at with this in
general
it might help it's it's hard to say I
mean I think at the end of the day it's
whether or not developers want to learn
this new technology and then implemented
and if I'm willing to bet dollars to
doughnuts here it's if anyone's gonna do
it's gonna be Sony first party but I
don't think we'll see third party really
kind of kind of dive into this and learn
how to use this this new technology I
think if anything we'll see use the
first party but yeah I mean I you know I
I've always thought that you know new
technology like this always receive
showing this technology always rests on
first party studios and I go back to you
know the the announcement the Xbox one X
true 4k and all that and I and I just
put all that and someone said snake oil
or something earlier look mark sorry the
smart guy means boring to listening to
on stage but
no he fooled the whole Sony conglomerate
in to believe in his stuff so he is a
very intelligent smart man understand
the process the process be money
actually says in the live chat big shout
out to be by the way it's up B says at
Ubisoft is using it on far cry 5 and
Bethesda using awesome side yeah yes
it's a big deal I mean what was your
finish law Brown yeah I mean for me at
the end of the day you know I specs are
nice and look these these companies are
they're tasked with with selling us you
know new hardware and getting us excited
and that's great but the other day as a
consumer I'm like okay that's that
sounds great but I want to see
real-world performance so I don't know
if this is gonna be a game-changer for
Sony because I don't know what the end
product is gonna look like using this
technology so until I see it you know
have a better understanding of the
impact no doubt yeah a low blow bra are
you coming from proofs in the pudding
yeah I mean this was interesting to me I
mean I'm glad loss saw brought it to the
table because um you know as a tech I
kind of love this kind of banter I'm not
gonna lie and it's one of those things
where you know kudos to Sony if it does
help that computational performance and
it does in definitely if it improves the
gap and obviously like you know Brad
said we have to see it in real world
application with these games which is
cool is that you know they are being
implemented with you know far cry 5 like
be money said and you know but that's
the users in on Wolfenstein so I mean it
will be really cool to see if like you
know
those digital foundry reports come out
and our man Richard Ledbetter he comes
through and he starts breaking down you
know titled by versus title and see how
performance is you know I will say this
you know it kind of only reminds me of
when dx12 was announced and y'all Xbox
one in honestly we didn't get to see
much of that intuition on that Hardware
so it's cool it will be cool to see how
that how the approach is transfer only
takes it and who actually implements it
because of ultimate like you know LeBron
said it's up to the developer to
implement this stuff into you know the
console and Charlotte anchorman to
charities and he's I just have in
destiny to as though excuse that to beat
86 these upgraded console so I'm not
good at this just like the good friends
at Bungie when you say God where did not
keep you when it's actually CPU bout so
let's not try to be armchair developers
sir he said this bank when they
announced the Xbox one X when it was you
know they little secrets system and he
said we actually we can do 12 mega flops
or teraflops of floating points and all
this other crap if you bring it down to
8-bit form we can we can listen bro yes
system is what it is maybe you can do
some trickery with in the system and a
software to boost it a little bit that
same trickery the same and be a GPU line
is the bloodline is the same in the next
box okay not to cut you but in his
defense I mean in the defense was this
article is coming out is that this is
something that the ps4 Pro did implement
that the Xbox one did not and they're
talking about true computational
performance 4.2 to teraflops to possibly
8.4
software right the thing about it it no
it's implemented into the hardware
basically the issue is this the caveat
related to this is this not every
operation can be situation I hope they
do anything for this PlayStation Pro
that I have in my house I hope they do
anything to get it to where it's super
enjoyable and it's fun they have some
good games good more - better you show
which actions but not one time without
buying any of those games for that
system cuz I know for a fact that no
matter what they do they're still not
gonna be on the xcalibur so I'm going
with the X on this I don't care what
blastmaster processing you're doing over
there but I'm gonna be over here playing
on hyperbole come on the leak all over
the place every hardware generation is
didn't this guy who yells out processing
power we have discovered it by the
button by the ones that are less
powerful always always here we go again
cell processing when Xbox was
water in these guys in the street if we
turn one on well hurry up and turn it on
flying wild hog and they actually make
believe it was a Shadow Warrior - and
they are like ranting and raving as far
as this um this tech and as far as the
ps1 Pro being a but I am Pluta lies it
and they say and the ability for the
conformity to two 16-bit operations
instead of one thirty two-bit operation
and they pretty much they were asked if
you know they they feel this had the
potential to radically increase the
performance range and they were like
raving and they were just talking about
they feel like this you know as far as
I'm not sacrificing image and quality
and that these precision instruction
they could get better performance so at
least one dev has stepped up and put put
their chest out in reference to rpm but
I'll move it back to a soft finish off
the topic yeah I mean honestly it's just
an interesting topic to talk about
because again like the whole secret
sauce thing with Xbox at the beginning
of the generation it just it just seems
like it's coming back around
um and then one thing you mentioned Lord
kognito that's very interesting is that
very easily this type of stuff can turn
into a big to big deal especially when
you consider digital founder he's gonna
get the hands on this stuff and break it
down um resolution gate happened as a as
a result of that and honestly like the
the waves of how this generation is gone
a lot of it was based on that early on
that early difference in terms of
resolution and stuff between the ps4 and
the Xbox one and stuff like that so if
this becomes a real issue and the dual
foundry is constantly breaking then
breaking this down game to game it you
know we're gonna see we're gonna see a
lot more conversations about this stuff
you know it's gonna be resolution get
all over again like I said the fun thing
about the fan boy stuff I must admit is
like sports teams and it's like I just
love that digital foundry has housed
these generations
you know fairway takes you
good at comparison to see who's gonna
rage out when one outperform the other
it would be funny I will say that but oh
we're gonna move on if the lords are
cool on the ps4 Pro the rpms and the
secret sauce kind of stuff and um we're
gonna move on so actually my boy Lord
addict he is not here yet so but I still
want to talk about it stopping real
briefly I get I like I guess I didn't
take off my bluetooth on my phone so I
didn't hear my alarm oh good then robbed
I was like to have a bit of this on
topics I was dying you mister Pole and
what did you talk to you about that most
one-sided poll in history
maybe I was gonna pass it off to you
that's gonna talk about real quickly
because I know it's one of the hottest
things out here as far as the law
breakers and cliffy B and I know you
wanted to bring that to the table so
yeah so what I really wanted to mention
and uh is as of right now we you know
the whole cliff bit cliffy
you know the give me a second I'm still
as right now you know law breakers you
we don't really know the sells on
PlayStation but looking like on PC you
know it's kind of you know been play
account slow yeah so what I wanted to
ask that the table is do you do you feel
that if this would have came out on xbox
would it have gotten better results than
it's getting as of right now
what's the jumping on the Legrand has a
lot sooner I remember I heard his topic
or deuce yeah actually I actually
watched his listen to his podcast slice
not at work yeah you know a couple
things you know I went in on the fanboy
piece because there's people out there
you know shouting all this is karma
or I hope the game fails this is what
you get clowns like seriously like
what's wrong with me what game are you
wishing you know a game to fail like
what's that about but that's that's
another rant you know we we actually we
talked about this I think two weeks ago
I think on Braff - I think with Randolph
4b you know I think most of us on the
panel and Brad thought that have the
game came on Xbox and maybe in one of
those games that actually might have
done better on exports because it's a
shooter right I know that shooters tend
to do well on that console and you know
I obviously we don't know for sure
but at least I found my opinion and this
is that it may have done better just
given how popular shooters are on the
Xbox console you know it's a it's an
online game you know you know we we see
the engagement numbers for Xbox Live
they're high
you know shooters tend to do well I mean
it very well could have done better
possibly don't know for sure yeah you
can never know for sure we'd ever know
yeah but but I'd say you know it with
with lawbreakers it's also it's an arena
based shooter you know it's kind of a
throwback to you know the the Unreal
Tournament
you know quake games you know how
popular are those games now a shooters
we have games out like destiny call duty
battlefield
you know I think cliff he's kind of in a
tough predicament - III don't know that
there's a demand for those kind of
shooters anymore Johnny Vaught a little
bit it's like I said for lord anchorman
like what I see on X I haven't played it
yet cuz I don't have a Playstation at
the moment but what I like noticed is I
feel like this game would have really
took off if overwatch wasn't already out
yeah I agree with that and I actually
agree with that study that's a good
statement and it didn't Lord overwatch
um drop some content also around the
same time huge up
that's kind of tough man um this is a
good one I just want to ask a little rap
one question before we pass it off to
the rest of the round table
um do you feel as far as I've been here
obviously I know you made a funny play
as far as like you know family saying
it's karma right you know what do you
feel about people who say you know
cliffy B you know he's very outspoken
and he's been on that Twiddy was in him
Twitter streets he was he was talking so
do you feel like you know some people
say like his over aggressiveness or
maybe you know I mean even make some
comments about I believe the Xbox
develop Xbox one X development cycle or
some little some look touchy subjects
that rub I guess some fanboys their own
way and stuff like that you know how do
you feel about his comments in general
you know in reference you know to this
kind of stuff trying to law breakers you
know I remember the comment about the oh
it's BS developers are lying to you or
something that effect you know I think
it was a response to is actually his it
was a response to somebody tweeting him
oh hey you know how come lawbreakers
isn't going to go on xbox you know it's
easy to port over to Xbox and he was
addressing that question um look I don't
have a problem with how we interact with
the community like but people act like
cliffy B you know just comes out and
just curses people out for no reason
it's like the guy like the guy who in an
Eric Jackson losing the live chat he he
got banned by this guy but Eric called
the eye out for throwing shade at cliffy
B but the guy was like tweeting all
Khalidi cliffy B told me to eat a bag of
I'm like wait a minute you're leaving
out the part where you basically accused
him of taking a payoff and this is the
problem like you can't be a keyboard
warrior throw a cheetah and with someone
punches back be like oh he hit me oh my
god you see what he did the way the
world works like if you throw if you
throw shade out there you're gonna get
shade back by people and you can't cry
about it
you can't go about it could you put
yourself in that situation I agree and
you got I got I got a give clear through
this and I'll pass off to a red flower
peasant
is that he's not afraid to mix it up
nope like take the high road and they
will he will get back in the mix and get
at you so shout out the Lord Eric
Jackson in the chat you know it's like
I'm glad he actually asked that fanboy
well what did you say to initiate said
comment you don't I mean and you know
again like a set for every action
there's an equal and opposite reaction
and boss has gone back but oh you're
looking well you want to jump in on this
as far as the lawbreakers think other
song go first I'll end up on it um I
think yeah I think it's very possible
that it could have done better on Xbox
just because of that association people
have a cliff Phoebe and the 360 in Gears
of War I mean people just they gravitate
to him like they sort of only him in it
that's not the right way to go about
things but at the same time that is the
feeling so that's why people you know
however ridiculous it is or not they
feel betrayed when he goes to their
opposing system but yeah I think
something that Brett mentioned also is a
big factor is the fact that these type
of games may not necessarily be popular
right now if it's kind of in the vein of
an unreal on even um they actually have
unreal champions coming out it's in beta
right now and again it's it's very much
an unreal game they haven't really done
much to it in terms of modernizing it um
as a right now you can really you can
pretty much run it on anything and it's
kind of it feels like it's a testbed to
see if people want this stuff and and to
be told the people who want unreal can
go play unreal but I don't think they're
gonna invest a serious amount of money
into it so again it may be this it may
be just a time and place thing that this
is not the the type of game that people
are looking for now first-person
shooters arena based or otherwise have
evolved a lot over the past 10 to 15
years
um and gamers are looking for something
different something more I think overall
the overwatch is so popular yeah and I
know we had many discussions about you
know a $60
declare only game but I think it's been
so popular because of the level of
polish that it has and and and how
animals characters
it is very balanced it is it lays it
plays kind of like an RTS with
first-person shooter sensibilities so
that you know that gives you kind of
more of an attachment to the characters
we're so far on these characters seem
like they're kind of kind of typical
archetypical like you know dudebro stuff
and stuff like that again I haven't had
a chance to look at it in depth but it
just seems like games with that sort of
dudebro mentality just don't fly as much
nowadays it's it's got to be it's got to
be more to it yeah I hear what you're
saying Lord Lord King you want to jump
in on this one cliffy well III I played
both versions of the game I played the
PC version twice and played the
PlayStation pro version twice um and I
came away from the game impressed but I
knew going up against overwatch you will
have a steep hill to climb because it
was so much like overwatch that it was
like overt well that comes now I was
gonna be compared to overwatch yea
battleborn that came out and they went
head-to-head with overwatch and he lost
miserably yeah at least lawbreakers came
out this far after overwatch because
this guy's getting compared to overwatch
but not nearly as bad as battleborn
but they're telling the numbers that
they did worse than battleborn
that's concerning if I remember
correctly battleborn pretty much didn't
make anyone make any money I don't
believe before was put on Xbox that it
would do the numbers that Xbox guys yeah
probably you know a little bit better
would it outperform all three platforms
I see in a landscape you would say the
PC where I'll perform both platforms but
being that overwatch is an investment
it's not just you know you put down your
$60 these guys have invested serious
amounts of time and money inside
overwatch and the content has been
regular yeah they're they've been
dropping down content so regular that
they have given you cheaper versions of
last year's content at the same time
that they dropped new content so they're
slashing prices on old content while
dropping new content so at any point in
time you jumping in you have of this
proffer of gaming tools at your hands
where you just get this new game that's
just launched and it's in its infancy I
don't believe that you know killer
Phoebe's name attached to it will push
sales because a lot of these people is
like who cliffy who and um if he is his
best market was Xbox he missed that
market I think the game would it did
poil poorly on xbox because it'll
probably been 720 because looking at
digital foundry the PlayStation 2 based
PlayStation has struggled to keep its 30
people been saying why don't you have
the 30 cap framerate and when I did play
it was slow even on the pro and that's
without all the effects on its 1440p so
it's not true 4k it's upscaled listen on
consoles this game it's not it's optimum
environment the optimal environment is
on the PC now if you want to release it
for the Xbox one X as an exclusive XP
see comparable game maybe they do well
there because there it can actually keep
that 4k framerate and at 60 frames per
second I believe because the game
doesn't show any technical prowess like
it can't be done
so maybe it might come out then maybe
he's holding that car for them but I
think the game dies before November oof
you know I think if it drives my xbox 1x
as an exclusive because it's cliffy B I
think it would probably do well I think
I think a lot of people who own Xbox one
X when it drops would go out and buy
this game because it's a it's it's our
next rosy frames let's assume they run
solid 60 and it's cliffy B they're mean
oh yeah like this games exclusive
one-on-one ex you know he's 50 B I think
people that hi ballon I think we're you
know turned out some decent sales for
him you know I agree I shot the most
fast back in the chat I mean he made a
good point he's like if what if you know
like I said they associated cliffie with
it in you know it was like some
exclusive Gears of War character almost
similar to kind of like how long was the
soccer game rocket League had employment
or halo um characters and so I mean halo
racers and stuff like that I mean it
could have been some real creative
things that they could have done with
marketing you know it's one of the
things like yeah I definitely feel like
as an Xbox 1x it would it would help a
little bit but I'm also really looking
in a sense that sometimes it's just
about timing you know sometimes it's
about timing of when you have a release
date and um you know I think the couple
with the fact overwatch is in that space
you know it's a battle you know to kind
of compete with that so I think it may
be one of those things is like a slow
burn where if you could appeal he
continued the support it continues to
add stuff it may bounce back almost like
a rainbow siege kind of thing but it
would have to be continued support I
feel you know they can't just walk away
from it you know if they if the initial
numbers you know don't do as well as
they they can so but um there's a
there's a good time anyone else had
anything else to say on all breaks
before we move on yeah I was gonna
actually call it off my topic I'm sorry
it's like white would this game have
done better on Xbox like you guys said
we have no clue I do feel like for the
most part you know shooters generally
gravitate towards Xbox you know people
get really mad when I say that that's
one of the reasons that single-player
games
flop on on um on xbox I mean look at it
you took her to the perspective of all
the single-player orientated games that
Microsoft has made this generation
they've all pretty much flogged what is
that what is Microsoft not made
multiplayer really multiplayer
experience besides halo halo I mean the
only game that they've really came out
with was titanfall and what did that do
you know what I'm saying so
I feel like it's just like um basement
radio say when you have a game that's a
shooter first off it's got to be a
shooter because that's the entire
infrastructure that's the whole
foundation that might that that might
strength effects this brand definitely
the strength of Xbox angry and you know
if they would have came out it would
have been exclusive not even just for
the X like now you know exclusive and PC
I do feel like there would have been a
more surge of of people picking it up on
the on the UH the Xbox but dude the
thing is is has the inflation has has
the the overwatch so big in the market
could it have made room regardless yeah
that's the day because I feel like I do
feel like that's the reason that it
flopped on PC is because people tried it
on the demo and was like this is
overwatch there but overwatch is better
I I do completely content that people
thought about that because if you think
about it on PC over watches way bigger
on consoles yeah so people didn't want
it the people that want to play the game
when they had a better version already
and it also ran into pub G on PC - it's
completely different from overwatch
that's why but like not to cut you love
Brad I also felt like that it just comes
down to timing man it's just too beast
you have one in its own genre and then
you have babji's like yeah I do want to
make a statement right now I completely
agree Fastback you're the only person
I've ever that's been in the chat that
agreed that corner break wasn't the
great escape or caught a break ready but
they had a lot of marketing about it
they're not the game changed a couple
times - I believe it did approach the
problem was yeah besides that it's just
the fact that for coming from remedy
were known for their shooting mechanics
the shooting mechanics in this game were
may
we're not very good that's disappoint it
felt like a last gen game for me to go
do that Lego project over there in the
corner we linked it straight to TV
that's why I think it went wrong is you
know it might not have so well but you
know people who play all of it I played
like 10 minutes of it but people who
they felt like it was a good game and
I'm just like look like that and what's
sad is that kind of game should've did
good on on xbox because you know that's
kind of you know the journal in junkie
game that is on xbox but it's like look
like when it comes down to it I felt
like the scenes were too long a lot of
you told me it felt like it disconnected
them yes absolutely so by the time
that's over you already done with the
whole game you know if I want to play
chapter 2 yeah disconnection I'm gonna
be honest a story I thought was cool
especially what happened with the girl
and how she got stuck back in time but
that could have been conveyed in
gameplay that could be why having a
flower movie behind it like I felt like
if you ever took the movie aspect and I
really like you know this is completely
left but I feel like if you would have
played as the antagonist when he was at
his prime I think the game would have
did way better because I felt like the
antagonist was more interesting than
main character studio they had all these
guys on the left for quite a break in
our loss often lean back to you I know
you wanted to talk about that hell-blade
tell the review and some other
single-player
you wanna talk about yeah absolutely um
so yeah I'm gonna talk about hell-blade
and my time within and what I thought of
the game and then I'm gonna segue that
into up kind of how that relates to
what's happening with single player
games now and and posted there that are
being utilized to sell a single player
game to single player content so well so
to start off like how blade sandwich
sacrifice is the latest game from the
guys at Ninja Theory so ninja theory the
guys you might remember them as the
developers of heavenly sword on the ps3
um they did enslaved Odyssey to the West
on the 360 and they were also behind DMC
Devil May Cry reboot with the crack head
Dante the play was great but crack kid
Dante not so much so right off the bat
if you're coming to this game with the
expectation that a ninja theory game
brings along with it which is you know
third-person combat heavy systems heavy
you know XP weapon and armor progression
action game you're gonna be disappointed
this game is not that game um hell blade
is a fairly linear narrative based third
person game it has some action elements
but it's definitely not not an action
game um it's actually kind of funny that
we're talking about about this game this
week because last week we were talking
about walking simulators and how I felt
that these type of games were only will
only really worked in first-person
because because you needed to feel like
you were kind of immersed in this
character's world and you needed to feel
like you were inhabiting this
character's persona in order to like
fully understand what was happening to
them within an area of the narrative of
the story and the game world but seonhwa
kind of immediately debunked that
because in essence it is a third-person
walking simulator um he'll play this is
Senlis story and every environmental and
gameplay element within the game is in
serve
of telling that story which is a very
very personal story so it makes no
mistake this is a narrative based game
right um so just to give a quick
overview of the overarching story
without spoiling anything not all the
basics thought through line of the story
um so the game is based in on Celtic and
Norse mythology so if you're familiar
with these stories and these names or if
you've watched uh you know a Thor movie
over the past couple of years you
probably might be immediately familiar
with names like Odin held free of
ruffians you know Odin hime Ragnarok so
all these thought all these uh terms
come up during the course of the game
and so basically um seonhwa is a celtic
warrior who suffers from psychosis or
schizophrenia which basically manifests
itself as hallucinations and also this
feeling that she hears multiple voices
in her head that's what I've been
hearing about the yetis voices yeah so
basically um when her entire village
including her not her husband basically
her beloved the one person that she's
always been an outsider because of her
because of this condition she has so the
one man who's ever paid her any mind and
sold her any compassion is murdered
along with the entire village and
they're murdered by Vikings um as a
result of this she has like a huge
psychotic breakdown and like her
feelings of guilt and responsibility for
it's happened kind of overcome her and
so what she does is that she ventures
out into the wilds basically trying to
gain access to the underworld
to gain access to the underworld to go
and save his soul and bring him back um
that's the crux of the story but the
thing is in doing that in doing that she
also has to combat and try to overcome
her affliction which in within the story
they call it the darkness basically
creepy man
I did I literally just watched a YouTube
video and I ironically had my head set
on that I got for me three so they're
real big on surround sound
I want like 22 seconds let's say yeah
they say for me yeah
freedom it's not even the way they're
talking it's not even what they're
saying it's just the way they're they
literally put put shivers down my spine
like it really did I love that I'm
actually ready I've heard people say
that the games actually given them
fatigue because it does such a great job
simulating psychosis with the voices
that people have had to stop playing the
game because it just became overwhelming
for them mental whoa whoa yeah they do
they do a fantastic job at conveying
that by the county it's really creepy I
like even if they tell you from the
outset play this game with headphones
not even surround sound play with
headphones because you get that sense of
a voice being right behind your ear and
it's all around you so yeah well I'll
segue into the gameplay um so that was
the basic crux of the story so gameplay
wise again it's very simple narrative
based linear gameplay you sort of
traverse the world by you got a pass
through doors that are locked by wound
symbols and basically you have to find
these symbols these shapes within the
world and kind of overlap them and find
them within the world and then focus on
them and that allows the the that opens
the rooms up and allows you to pass
through the door so that's basically the
crux of the traversal of the game are
you trying to make your way to the
underworld um if there's a criticism my
half of the game is that that it feels a
little clunky sometimes it's so cos not
the most intuitive sometimes if you
can't find the room with in the world
because again it could be hidden in the
architecture it could be hitting like on
the floor or like you have to look
around and find it quickly a cut it can
kind of slow the pace of the game
to a crawl like to get a little
frustrating so that that's a little
wonky but yeah besides that it's fine um
in terms of the combat the combat again
is very straightforward and simple um
combat is only available in
combat situations like you can't just
while you're walking around the world
you can't pull your soda out start
swinging like it it's not available to
you only when a combat situation is
presented yourself you see this you
little sharp hook she'll pull her sword
out and allow you to fight welcome back
and hyper to side of the South game is
something else like so look at the
combat is again a light swipe heavy
swipe melee attack evade and block now
do they mess with you with whatever
condition during the fights during the
fights
yeah well see what I want is that what
you fight someone and he pulls back and
then her condition starts going up and
you see like three of them you have
moments who will be fighting three or
four at the same time and generally all
of the guys that you're fighting don't
feel like they're like normal warriors
like they do feel like they have a
supernatural element to them so yeah and
all like because this is these are
manifestations in her head and yeah you
will fight you will fight for at a time
sometimes and you have to dodge around
them um and in that the game the game
the fighting is beautiful um but it's
very similar it's all about learning
seeing patterns blocking dodging around
guys um you also have a focus button and
when you hurt them enough you can focus
and you slow down time and you can do
more damage on them so so that's the
calm that's the combat um graphics this
game is stunning absolutely
ninja Terry's always been known for
their work on mocap um and with this
game they take it a step further with um
with in terms of facial mapping the
actress that plays Sanwa who is actually
not really an actress she's one of the
devs um she decided they put her into
the night cap wearing one yes she's one
of the dead okay okay cool um so they
put her into the mocap thing one day to
see you know to see what would happen
and they just stuck with her and she
does an absolutely amazing job
um so the game is absolutely beautiful
honestly the the environments are
fantastic but
it's very linear you can't you can go we
can walk around to the sides of things
but not really is that open really um
but the vistas are beautiful um what
else was I gonna say like little things
like water effects aren't necessarily
the greatest when the water hits onto
the beach it doesn't look super great
but the waves do look fantastic um when
she walks into the water she doesn't
come out wet so just little things like
that that you know it's not a hundred
triple a game um one of the most
fantastic aspects of this game is the
sound like we talked about performance
um they use it binaural yeah what they
what they use is what they call binaural
recording so basically what the actors
did is they had them walking around
literally walking around a microphone
recording their lines so that the voices
come from different from different
angles so when you're playing the game
um they could be any number of voices
talking to you you have one general
voice that it's a female that kind of
narrates scentless story and talks about
more about like her condition what she's
going through and then you have multiple
other voices that I mean they can be
they could be berating her they can be
insulting her they could be supportive
they can tell her don't do this do this
as a matter of fact in combat oftentimes
when somebody's behind you they'll tell
you behind you and then you'll have to
duck and get out of the way oh nice so
but again the voices can be the voices
can be tree I mean that to me the sound
is one of the greatest triumphs of this
game so yeah yeah actually I mean again
to wrap it up quickly um I think this is
it's a beautiful game I think it should
be experienced by every single gamer um
it does an excellent job of conveying
mental illness in a very like respectful
way enik and what it does what it does
is convey
what happened was showing mental illness
in a very respectful really sad ways
when you do something and you don't take
the time to do it properly and convey it
correctly you couldn't you can insult
someone they do they put a lot of
research into psycho and forthright Wow
the team was really small tool that did
it well that's gonna okay let's say wait
let's say wait again the game's
fantastic everybody needs to play it
it's fantastic Oh way into my next thing
again I want to talk about address how
this game was made because this game
from the very beginning Jerry dubbed it
as an indie triple-a game they decided
not to go would have baked their party
publisher they published in house they
developed in house 15 members of Ninja
Theory worked on his game bin team the
budget for this game is somewhere around
10 million dollars a 10 million dollar
budget for this game that is a gift we
made it back to oh yeah I think they
needed to sell something like 500,000
copies somewhere else to make it back um
so well that's going to push north of a
million because it was oh yeah I did
well word of mouth word of mouth alone
the PC version again the ps4 version pro
version looks fantastic they're adding
HDR later on so it's gonna be the more
view of HDR yeah and the PC version has
to be amazing so in talking about how
this game was made right small team
small budget excellent price point but
triple-a sensibilities and you think if
you want to think about now how a lot of
our first-person games are coming down
the pipeline especially with this talk
of the shadow of Mordor getting of
shadow war scuse me out of war getting
microtransactions and blind loot boxes
do you
think that developing a game in this way
the way the way it helped late was made
is that a viable solution to us to
continue continuing to get solid
first-person stories in the future all
we kind of stuck with this model that
there it's starting to implement now
with bigger bigger single-player games
where they're gonna start charging us
and potentially kind of grossly start
charging us for single-player content
kind of play to win content in a
single-player game blind loot boxes
where you can spend an insane amount of
money before you get what you want so
what do we think is this the model that
we're gonna see or should we see more
with seonhwa I feel like do I think that
everyone's just gonna change because
this is gains being successful uh that
that's that's a hard thing to ask
because I feel like you know for the
most part this might be an exception to
what would do good but you know all the
all this game does is make games like
record look horrible dollars cheaper
than record it makes record look bad
visually looks bad every wise it could
possibly do so you know I do feel like
certain companies have are trying this
is like you know I brought a free court
do I feel like other companies might
jump on this site I feel like for the
most part these have you know the
hell-blade it's unique and I think
that's what's making you sell more not I
think people would have paid $60 for
this title yep so you know maybe it
wouldn't be as sold as it is but I feel
like you would've did good at 60 I mean
when it comes to the game itself I
couldn't tell you anything about it you
know why because at you know our last
topic again microcell it's either just
look at their fingers this topic again
Microsoft slipped through their fingers
I ain't played navier-- these guys would
be talking about you know they're gonna
let everything go to the PlayStation
first so wrapping with a jumping on this
hell blade as well as the single player
model yeah absolutely and the single
player things is
in something that's been you know talked
about a lot more recently given you know
Phil Spencer's comments a couple months
ago about story driven games verse yeah
getting to the service I would say one
thing though if you don't mind me
interrupt you
this is definitely like you know would
you guys think this game existed of you
know developers like telltale didn't
make clicking adventures mmm it's tough
one it's a tough one home it's just a
model man yeah I do feel like this will
evolve that drone or even more yeah yeah
I think yeah I think ninja theory they
made it clear like they said you know
what this is a game that we wanted to
make for a long time and we didn't want
any interference from from a publisher
anything like that so we decided to make
it in-house and and use our own funds
and just to make the game we wanted to
make if that means that they had to kind
of yeah hold back on certain technical
aspects of it it's not evident in the
game at all right shout out the low
Megatron in chat you're going that blood
attic he's like hey relax he loved
reclaim go ahead how many people beat
the game as how many people purchase the
game I actually really like the game um
and I love the art direction of the game
so I'm not gonna bag on recall I
actually looking forward for record was
promised about Rico I've been buried no
no so we thought what that conversation
has been having you know that that you
know because of Phil Spencer's comments
about first party games and you know
games of services and first party
single-player driven games not really
having legs in terms of generating
revenue over a period of time
and the increasing cost of game but
let's face it like people want 4k but
they don't understand that when you want
4k and now developers have to create 4k
assets that that also increases the cost
of develop nobody wants 4k people would
just got the perception that in people's
heads that people want more
I I'll take 1080p60 all day fax talking
and I think I can get on my soapbox and
talk about 4k me too Oh be so but yeah I
mean I think my phone this is I I really
wanted to see this game do well and it
sounds like it is doing well because
ninja theory they set out to make a game
with triple-a production values that
didn't you know blow the budget that
would give gamers you know a nice seven
eight hour experience and they did that
and I think that that shows that you
don't have to have a two hundred million
dollar budget to put out triple-a tied
game that's good I think they've shown
that you don't have to do that and I
think that this is a great thing for the
industry and I hope a lot of gamers go
out and support this game because I want
to see more games like this I want to
see games that are $30 that give me good
eight hour experience that give me
triple-a value that have a strong
single-player narrative driven content
that's what I want and you can't meet
that for $30
there's games that that are that are $60
Santini's do that and then have hundred
million dollar budgets so you kind of
think if if a team of 15 can do it why
can't a team of a hundred do it you know
you know what else is pretty funny
mm-hm and in the chat acting like he
wants to play 4k so he can play Friday
and and 2k more better there are some
advocates for it but I agree with with
labrat man I mean you know I take 1080
60 every day I mean III hear what you
don't get me wrong I'm not gonna not
want 4k I have a 4k television and I
love HDR I think honestly I think HDR's
talked about enough I feel that's what I
think that's the difference I think
Microsoft and Sony has to successfully
turn the entire console industry into a
bunch of PC people native you know
they're doing 1440 60 frames no exactly
so yeah like obvious a bit dissident
topic
right I'm very excited about it um
sounds of me this is definitely getting
it up my alley
that's amazing like little Bram said I
mean this is beating a lot of triple-a
$60 titles you know they could have
easily charged 16 I think they would
still one hour purchase thing so I mean
the only thing I want to bring as far as
a single player model is just that like
I think ultimately you know this is a
lot of discussion going on right now
that I'm seeing in the industry as far
as you know how does a single pop single
player model move forward you know and
you got a thing like the opposite was
slightly safe or like a shadow of war
that's coming right and we obviously
heard about those microtransactions and
stuff like that and I'm in the boat
that's like you know what I don't want
the single player model to jerk to die
you know and it's one of those things
that we've got after that we've got to
go out and support these quality games
like a hell blade just get a bunch of
mediocrity for the rest of our life I'm
also gonna say some controversial I also
feel that like a shadow of war you know
when they introduced microtransaction
everyone those two hands oh this is a
travesty I will not buy this game
because of that you know you get you
have to vote with your wallet but I also
understand the production cost of these
games you know and like Phil said you
know he wasn't trying to disrespect
single-player games but if you look at
it from a long-term perspective it's
it's not viable I'm on top a
single-player game when you beat that
game it's done right there's really no
incentive to come back unless there's
some DLC content or something after that
you know and you look at a multiplayer
game I say for example like a NBA 2k hey
Lord King no who's like $60 on VC for
virtual currency for their NBA guy dark
a certain way look a certain way exactly
so you can't you I can't get mad at the
single-player devs and I'll give it you
am and yet it like this city like look
how can we get a piece of this pie to
continue to support the game now do I
agree with all practices no there are
some that are shady so you have to vote
with your wallet but I can't
get mad at the single-player dev that
says you know what we gotta try to do
something to generate revenue you know I
mean so I don't want ultimately I don't
want the genre to die you know I want to
support games like hell but I had a
question for the turnaround thing real
quick um is there any justice take its
comin xbox so this is just an engine of
theory this is strictly and Sonia in
happening because it has become I think
this is the JIT we only had enough money
for one port at the time because they
you know it costs like $5,000 to give a
certification patch to these consoles
just a match imagine what it to put an
entire game up for certification mm-hmm
facts looking I said I was gonna get
into the game if it would have been
along the vein of what was that hell
blade the first one what was it and he's
heavily sword
yes heavenly sort see um that was one of
my best saw a PlayStation 3 launch
titles I thought it was fantastic I love
the fact that you know they took the God
of War and had a female god war type of
thing
and I guess they didn't want to
competing um like hack and slash on the
same system coming from first party
developers and they just like lost
funding because I think how blade was
supposed to be in that same vein and
they went in a different direction these
guys didn't give up their dream and they
stuck with it and from all intensive
purposes they achieved their goal with
with the 15 people the mocap from a
developer that was in-house so they kept
all the money closed they kept
everything closed and they found new and
special ways to keep the single player
engaged from what I'm hearing like the
headphones put your headphones on
remember a GUI user sitting out one what
I have phones on our parents trying to
be quiet and play
like Resident Evil and Silent Hill and
we think it might be quite because you
want to immerse yourself in that kind of
experience
absolutely they're bringing that feel
back Oh for us bringing it back and
introducing this feel for the new gamers
to feel that immersion no not
necessarily
oh my friend is online let's get online
and that loud chatter and that all that
is no no no tone it down
getting a dark put your headset on and
get immersed into psychosis this game
would actually mess with me Reza D was
seven didn't too much but I feel like
this game enough you know that maybe
jump but like I even joke with you guys
thirty seconds of this game had
shivering like a spine it was just the
why I never see her audio like that it
was like what is this chick talking
about man like Taemin for me it being a
backlog I will definitely get it at
being a backlog um because I just picked
up a sauna fire from our PlayStation so
and I'm gonna get into that that JRPG
but this experience is something that I
want to experience and any gamer that's
feeling a lull in video games right now
who happens to have that one console or
both consoles dive in it's cheap enough
for you to jump in without a need of
remorse buyer's remorse afterwards and
you might be treated to something
fantastic put those Call of Duty
headsets to work right now yeah dams if
any of these devs are watching this if
you make you gain $30 some so you know
some gamers look at your game would be
like if it sucked I only paid thirty so
people will take a risk for $30 yeah you
know what they will it desperate it's
it's it's it's a softer blow than saying
oh you know I think when you make a game
$60 they and you know it's fair
comparison it is they can pay your stuff
to call a duty to destiny they compare
it to anything else of the $60 price tag
no no absolutely this is a great great
car it's often even glad you definitely
reviewed that game because people need
to hear about it and I love to promote
quality titles like that and you know
it's good to see the single player
showers still live and strong you know I
mean and definitely definitely a hot
topic
so what's got anything else to say you
want help late and single play for all I
have to say is look at this a makes me
Loki want a ps4 yo when it comes to it's
like look like you know I want this game
to do five million plus I want this game
to be so successful that people can't
overlook it because I'm so sick and
tired of the same you know what kills me
these days about single-player
experiences is people make some bad
single-player experiences in the wonder
why they flopped mmm and it's like look
you know multiplayer is a little bit
different perspective because you can
put your friends you know the
experiences you have with your friends
and it heightens the whole game it's
like Friday trash but because of my
friends it was fired so you know like
you got you know multiplayer you the
multiplayer aspect can make the game
better but when it comes to
single-player you are being I
undoubtedly you are being compared to
fallout you're being compared to shadow
4 you're being compared to Skyrim
because these games they're the best
single players out there and you know
people when you have third party good
single-player games they generally make
them good but for some reason people
will make bad single-player games like
quantum break and be like why they're
myself
sunset overdrive is a fun game I
promoted it from trash to average okay
that is a lot for me okay but my issues
with some of these games is I don't
understand who they're for
it's like sunset overdrive it's a fun
game but it's like you know it it had it
maybe it's just not apparently it's not
for the majority because that game so
Lord maybe
I'm the majority and you got all want to
go into it too because obviously the
sales do reflect that it didn't do as
well as it should all I'm saying
let you finish I'll let you finish all
I'm saying is that sometimes you do need
diversity titles on a console that's all
I'm saying oh I agree
no I'm not saying like you know
Microsoft is stop making single-player
experience games it's ludicrous Oh Lord
egg is coming for you he says so that
sunset overdrive is better than Halo
Wars - it's about hey I bet you Halo
Wars 2 has made more money than sunset
overdrive money without the halo title
that's the question so the way did
without the insomniac brain behind that
so yeah once again everybody play the
game get the gameplay English where you
can in terms of the the single-player
stuff my I don't I'm ok with any of the
models that are out now even even the
just gotta make good games the DLC stuff
and even the pay2win stuff cuz it's a
single-player thing if it only affects
you you want to run around that world do
whatever you want my only worry and it's
something that we didn't touch on is the
fact that
the potential for them to develop the
game with that grind enos in mind to
sort of force you into wanting to buy
that content to sort of skip over stuff
that they purposely hey they obviously
made grindy like if you look at if you
look at phone games and how they're
created it created in such a way that
makes you want to keep spending money on
them um and I'm afraid that that that
will influence how single players are
made and everything all I know is
hell-blade done put the boot on some of
these devs throats good Microsoft can't
make another record what I get it and
I'm gonna bring this one to the
roundtable so um obviously we know the
Xbox one you I dropped recently for
those in the Alpha ring and I wanted to
talk about a lot of people you had loved
up still haven't haven't had it but I
want to talk about the good in the bad
and ultimately if I'm constant
iterations of the OS or good long-term
so before I bring it around Terence one
exception
does anyone here and around table have
the new UI yet no that program I jumped
out if I brought a whole new Xbox to get
rid of that crap it wouldn't let me out
at all it kept loading that crap up into
my system and I had to sell my my Call
of Duty system system that I liked a lot
to get away from that back up so you
know what I did I went to factory
setting game stop you lost the food at
that you must have booted the feedback
thing of when you booted the guess I
guess you don't know how get you some
out of a simple program exactly if you
don't like what your PC did you get rid
of them by normal that's it but Laura
man have you
even have this UIC's I'm curious I see
you on Twitter talking the most dirt
about this new ID I don't even think you
have it when Lord kognito says his stuff
he don't like about he has legit stuff
that he don't like about it
this news saying he don't like because
there's too much space between this tile
in this style light Lord Eggman you do
have the answer that hey it doesn't look
as bad as you be claiming this doobie
look this do be saying this thing looks
like the front of a dumpster like that's
it I'm the only one that has it right
now I'll make this quick um I'll talk
about the good I mean first of all it's
zippy fast the speed is definitely a
good issue you know there's some great
customization options as far as um just
moving the home screen around be able to
customize kind of things that you want
on your home screen so they really
supporting this full customization
aspect um there's also cool thing for
the techies about adjusting your neck
your NAT settings and that's wrong from
network perspective when you're having
issues and stuff so actually gonna be
big huge that's huge arm also a big
thing that I think they don't promote
enough about it is you know as a guy
like myself and lord King us as premium
experienced guys we tend to have
multiple systems you know you may have
one Xbox in level one in the bedroom you
know you may you know just be planning
to buy an xbox one s or the Xbox one X
when it comes out so one thing that
sucks is if you are an external hard
drive user to be able to copy games one
at a time and they finally like have
this bulk copy and move option which I
love you know so that two most
tremendous and I think that's gonna be
cool especially you know when the Xbox
when X comes out and a lot of people
don't have to transfer that date over
you know all those digital games and
things that because you know I'm all
digital just for the record but um so we
got that and now the bad um first off
it's semi customizations that full
because I'm a big proponent of no the
club's feature and I was trying to put
the I'll or podcast Club got a ton of
members in shot everybody was most
important in my on Xbox Live and it
jumped in it
I can't get that on my home screen you
know Xin and then there's some things
that are kind of silly on the UI like
this I mean shout out the law valleca
and I give them so much crap and Lord
knows like Lord vaya con is stuck on my
screen at the top of the homepage
telling me to join him and I'm like I
don't want to do it if I want to remove
this from my screen but there's some
things that are there as far as that and
you know just these random Microsoft
features that are trying to be pushed
and promotions and shut up to uh get
spots to and Randolph going those guys
you know I heard Mike Ibarra was on and
he said that that's early stage that
stuff is just I heard you know you watch
that don't say I heard fast Mike you
know he didn't give any feedback let's
just be real here no feedback he's just
bitching that first of all hey I gave
feedback
I am defeat well I'm talking about
anchorman okay
I had to give feedback when stuff you
know that I didn't like so um yeah I
mean it's just one of those things that
um you know Michael Barr knows guys were
saying that you know that algorithm
stuff and that's in the early aspect
that that's definitely getting changed
so I was happy to hear that you know I'm
saying but um the main beef I have with
HR is they have the new guy button you
press it and it has a lot of stuff that
you can access however things like just
adding someone into a party it's you
know chatting you know with your friends
it's like four steps that you have to
now drill down into just to get the same
effect so something as simple as okay I
want to do a party chat and you know I
want to grab you know friend a B and see
what they would normally take about
maybe one or two steps not takes for
because these O's these submenus that
you have to drill down to very annoying
and the the last thing I want to talk
about it is a reference to the um
achievements now again Mike Ibarra
these guys said that you know they they
plan on doing something really special
achievements and it was very important
to me
from the standpoint speaking or the rare
ones you know stuff that you buy the
only one that wants like a platinum that
row that trophies has like to have all
them like what could they even call that
an achievement for all the achievements
something man right a gold achievement
maybe your app you say something I would
say like the grand achievement or
something I don't know I like gold I
think did you know and my thing is I
don't know if you guys remember a couple
of you eyes have some diamond
achievements getting up to down when it
makes the cool sound when a lot of your
rare achievement rattles yeah yeah the
community doesn't have a lot of it but
the thing that pissed me off I don't
know if you guys remember a couple of
urs back
they had this thing called achievement
showcase and I know Lauren anchor knows
what I'm talking about because basically
no I didn't know they took that out
because here's the thing this is my main
beef with this whole thing right and I'm
about to go and this is Lord cocky
little ring my thing is I'm all about
them being a software company and making
iterations and proving it but one thing
that's my pet peeve is don't take
features away from me that you added
like that showcase thing was old like I
literally had five of my most favorite
achievements and it had the achievement
art and it was associated with profile
so you know yet I had my chest out like
you know it was a badge of honor I had
you know a lot of these achievements in
this and these beautiful artwork and now
it's gone there's no talk of it coming
back and that's my thing right now
sometimes I feel these iterations you
know take things away that actually
we're good so I want to bring that to
the table you know what are you get what
are the Lord's thoughts on this anybody
can jump in as far as the UI situation I
guess I can go first since you know the
chat hates me right now for going in on
Microsoft this one but let's go and
again it's not that they you know I've
all I'm all about Microsoft innervating
their software system I feel like they
do it too much and I feel like the way
to balance that is they have a setting
of when you first launch the system from
factory settings it's like this is do
you want your your your menu vertical do
you want horizontal and then you click
that that it says do you want paddles do
you want it
just let me customize it the way I want
to never mess with it again actually
and I feel like you know and it's it's
not a big deal
like you know for the most part you know
it's like lord Cognito was in like this
special special special group so like
there's probably five thousand people
with this thing probably a little more
than that obviously but it's not a big
deal but the big deal is people are
trying to act like because they're doing
a UI updates they're attacking no games
updates so yeah it's like they could
shows when people would Microsoft
launches a new controller they're like
they're doing new controllers but no
games like people don't realize these
are different these are completely
different teams that have nothing to do
with each other
like the mic your borrows whole team has
nothing he even said on the Xbox to I
have I am in charge of a lot of things
but games that was his exact words so
it's like if they were popping in first
parties they would be you know there's
obviously be negative feedback this
stuff they don't like but no one would
be coming at it nearly as bad as they
are now because you know there's a lot
of go and I was like you're putting all
this time and effort into your UI but
you got no games on it and I think
that's one of the reasons that it's
getting a lot of bad publicity anyone
was jumping labrat yeah I mean I you
know my thing with this is I mean how
many more UI iterations we're gonna have
with them like I mean like look I
obviously it made sense when you drop
the Kinect you had to tweak things but
Jesus I mean this is like the fourth or
fifth time already and look I like the
home screen looks nice it looks clean
but I mean like why do they keep doing
these iterations why do they keep
approving things it sounds like I think
lorkhan you know you mentioned that with
the with getting into a a party chatter
inviting a friend like it now it's like
two or three extra steps you know
they're gonna go back and revamp it
again I mean it's like it's great that
they want to listen to you know feedback
but get something together and just
stick to it and just tweak things I mean
look what Sony does with you know with
the with our UI they haven't had like
these major like changes
change things they've updated things
they tweak things but for the most part
the UI is the UI that we got and that
we've got some angry last four years
exactly it's a jump on your point mud it
doesn't have don't you for that promotes
a consistency in familiarity yeah it's
always this relearning it's like we
always have to go to school again and
how are we gonna do it's like class
every quarterly with the big yeah it's
gonna start becoming a running joke I
mean I really I really think I mean it
has I mean it's become a running joke
with the controllers and how it's coming
and running joke with the UI I think I
think Lord addict mentioned you know
with the games thing it only kind of
highlights
you know the UI and and and possibly you
know gives in to a lot of that
negativity towards the new UI that's
come out so I just look we live in a day
and age where people want to give us
custom let us do the entire thing how we
want it but again yeah but people want
familiarity they want to be able to like
like with our computers with our phones
we want to be able to go on logon know
everything is and and and have ease of
access to it and that's it that's all
you want so on
yeah III definitely agree with you you
know I it's like I really do feel like
if they would just let you customize
every aspect of your dashboard like just
one update they got and you know that
would be a lot they would have to focus
on but I feel like if you know they
focus a lot of resources on that
particular update they would never have
to mess with again unless something's
messed up and with them and yeah but I
do have one request as Mike if I was
watching this and they are considering
something like this make sure anchorman
has the one we have now forever this UI
situation I think every time this
systems my new system is coming out
they're gonna put out and know and if
to make it feel fresh they don't want to
release a new system with our old
interface mm-hmm okay as you do so
pretty much nothing bad it's just yeah
soid I need your feedback on this that
that makes sense what Lord King is
saying but at the same time it's like if
you're going to do that release it with
the system don't believe them don't do
this a month in advance because then
when you when you really someone's in
advance you put yourself in it the way
she will your we have to iterate again
this is the beta they could be releasing
that with the game with the actual
system oh absolutely check you know
people asking that you do you think that
this is going to be because of the Xbox
one X coming if that's why they're
trying to utilize this kind of you I
think we're gonna got this if Xbox one X
wasn't here they did this last year it's
not because of that system they have
changed it I don't even remember what it
looked like when it came out like the
original light I remember it look
drastically different I mean it and
what's funny is people don't realize
they did this in the 360 it was like
every year year and a half we got a new
up a new dashboard
they changed something almost yearly on
the on the dashboard for the 360
I remember for for the top of my head
four different dashboards for the 360
blows oh yeah I think for me it's just
like at this point them being in the
position position that they're in second
place far back in second place it's just
it's it comes off as you have nothing
else to show so let's do let's change up
the UI and give them something to talk
about um they got grant down it comes
off it comes off as you're not confident
in it cuz you're constantly changing it
and it not in that not to the point
where you're just tweaking it you're
just revamping the whole damn thing like
you can't make up your mind and that's
the way it comes off when you were in
the 360 era when they were doing it they
were on top of the world all third
parties ran best on on their system the
conversation was a they're constantly
refreshing the system while look at this
positive thing that they do
now it comes off is they don't know what
they're doing constantly keep tweaking
it comes off as as insecurity a little
bit yeah I feel you and my last point
today great boy gets all finished off
and I got a point tonight too especially
when you're doing things like I
understand the desire to make the splash
page as clean as possible you know for
me yeah definitely get rid of all those
of the boxes that ask me to buy
something or whatnot but when the
cleanliness of the splash page comes at
the expense of ease-of-use and now you
have to go four or five steps in to do
something they could require two steps
that's a problem that's a problem you're
giving up something positive for what I
don't you're not getting that much in
return and again the opinions that
pinyon speak on it it's like I'm gonna
have to go to five steps to do something
simple doesn't make any sense to me
absolutely my last point is for the
cherry on top of it it's obvious made me
think of something it just look I don't
want to be you know Debbie Downer with
the thing like I'm I'm mad at innovation
I'm always I'm always liking the fact
that they are trying to improve
something but I guess I'm more excited
about them adding features but keeping a
base you I unless something is
completely broken my issue is what was
so broken about the last UI that we have
to revamp just like hey I'm all about
those cool new features I'm all about a
tweak let's do it out there and it shot
to the chair they've got some good stuff
you know make sure you guys get feedback
you know that's one thing I have to give
Microsoft credit they do listen to the
feedback you know when people who you
know put their comments too much right I
do want to say something real quick oh
yeah I just dropped the feedback website
thing they have yeah everyone in this
chat go to that and vote to put YouTube
on the Xbox cuz I want to call out Mikey
gars blah
because he said in that podcast he said
we will do it if it gets enough click so
I'm like ok ok we're gonna get it enough
click I think it's something eternal I
think that's the reason it's not there
Jessie that's all I got in the UI would
be to death let's move on let's get this
thing going
Lord King got something to talk about
with Grandpa Nintendo and amiibos it's
really with Grandpa Nintendo and arms me
bows is like a side plot today I think I
think Nintendo has found a way to put us
in a preview program without letting us
know crack tonight I really think they
have duped us anybody has picked up arms
and I picked up arms it's not the same
arms that you got day one brother it's
all totally different arms now are they
tweaked it there's no worse than
fortnight no no no see what what you did
get was you got a game that was a
functional game and what they what what
I expected like from Grandpa Nintendo
and what grandpa Nintendo does best is
father knows best
I wouldn't anyone from Nintendo's of her
watched our podcast be like why they
keep calling us grandpa because I found
out what's Reggie's been up to sliding
little Trojan horses into our console
slots this game is a preview program
game extra characters that give you
tweaks to the game and they updating it
and Nintendo has grown because before
they would just put out a game and
that's it so Nintendo has
on the way to put you in a preview
program for again because remember this
game came out at a time where they
needed a game to fill a slot because
they had a low so I think the game was
rushed to be put out but it was in a
finished enough stable form to simulate
a complete game and they said well over
time we'll just give them stuff they
won't complain and because at first when
the game was launched it didn't feel
like a $60 game it actually felt like a
thirty dollar game I was very upset that
I that I spent $60 then it goes back to
the UH the hell-blade you spend $30 you
couldn't get upset about it you just
chucked it up like ah spend $30 for it
was great it was good but whatever and
you came out on top yes I spent $60 and
I was mad because some place else
you must be energized sleeping in that
corner for this guy oh my god but I just
want to know do you guys feel cheated or
feel rewarded that Nintendo actually
went back into the game and gave you
some of the stuff that we was asking for
in a beginning and does it feel like
it's a $60 purchase now opposed to when
you first purchased it is just going to
the people who bought arms question did
you buy off what you are you willing to
buy
my arms now that you heard that no it's
actually a better game than when it
launched I know nothing about arms I
didn't know it got better well I just
assumed it was the same consistent
updates recently um obvi I think that's
good like you know regardless how how
you feel about that you know I mean
there's a lot of games that do it do you
necessarily think people who bought GTA
5 at launch is getting robbed because
it's better than it was at a launch yeah
shout out the Lord carbot so in a chat
he's saying what's the difference
between this and fighting games that
balance updates and characters it's $60
for arms is $60 I'm just saying I think
it's worth the $60 because it looks fun
it does look fun I think it absolutely
is I knew it was a little undercooked
when it launched um but at the same time
Nintendo's done this with the new IP
when they're not a hundred percent sure
how it's going to be reacted to they did
it with splatoon so 2-1 came out very
undercooked with a very little content
and when they saw people gravitated to
the gameplay
I guess this all the stuff was in the
works already but they made sure this is
40 just support it maybe like two years
into the the lifespan of the game that
was still dropping new things so the
same is gonna be true for this I mean
arm sold was over near damn near a
million and a half copies YUM
they're gonna continue to support it but
again it was one of those things that if
it's sold 50,000 copies they were you
know they weren't gonna put that much
more money and effort into it you're
gonna get some stuff maybe for the
remainder this year and maybe that's it
um but with the community behind it
you're gonna see more of it so I yeah I
don't think it differs that much from
fighting games and changes and additions
to characters and stuff like that um
it'd be interesting to see
interesting to see how they do it with a
single-player game that isn't you know
because you have arms as a multiplayer
fighter on splatoon as a multiplayer
shooter so it'd be interesting if they
brought up some new IP that wasn't in
those two genres and to see how they
handle that do they go all in from the
jump and give you a full-on experience
so they sort of piecemeal it to you but
again we haven't seen single-player I
appeal that new stuff from them for a
long time so I mean they could always do
a destiny did Locke a whole race and
unlock it later
I will admit like first of all I think
the game is very unique it's balanced
and the thing I like about is that I
wasn't forced to use monster controls
which I've actually liked that aspect
it's colorful cool art style I like the
game um I will say this to Lord Kings
point though I do feel yes the online
features are cooled is the basketball
thing you dunk your opponent in three on
three two one two all this stuff I do
feel from a single player standpoint it
is bare-bones in that aspect so you know
I do understand what he's saying as far
as that maybe it kind of launched kind
of bare-bones II and then kind of got
better with each subsequent update and
things of that nature you know in its
defense though I will say this the
updates are free you know I mean they
could easily hit us with the you know $5
for max brass DLC they could have you
know so that's why I kind of respect the
fact that every update and every balance
patch has been free you know and I mean
now your other topic which we'll get
into which I'm dying to chomp at the
bribe you you go to home own arms you
know what I did not pick up arms but hey
anytime we get free content or updated
concept for a game support I'm all for
it as long as gonna charge anything
extra good cool all right look
Kings back on you
me bows is a serious moneymaker this
time if you really want this content so
they took one of their favorite IDs game
that we've been waiting for the remake
to Metroid on his returns now as I told
you that was available did you I didn't
need about it thank you sir I'm happy
that you did I use I just want to say is
the guests here on the podcast I do
agree with Lord addict that that is kind
of pay-to-win
I'm not saying do it you ought to do it
didn't do it I'm not saying it's right
or wrong but in certain aspects it was
only outside but I know I have a
purchase you didn't so I um but I also
purchased other amiibos and they were
cosmetic I was clothing that you
received for it was all cosmetic stuff
it was it wasn't anything that stopped
you from completing any part of the game
it wasn't anything locked behind an
amiibo that you couldn't achieve
regularly you just got the me bows and
they gave you food and it was no pay to
assess and I purchased every amiibo like
I was on a me bow hunt
I told neato about the wolf amiibo he
went out and he got it cuz he saw it he
thought it was cool um but grandpa
Nintendo has taken this to another level
people
now those two amiibos that I told you
about the samus amiibo and the Metroid
amiibo they come in a dual pack best buy
is selling it and you can get it on
Amazon now it's sold out on Amazon now
and I'm pretty sure that these amiibos
will be going for upwards of 75 to $100
on the second-hand market to get these
because behind these amiibos and you
need these immeubles to get out locked
portions of the game that's actually on
the cartridge apparently it's it's it's
a fusion it's called fusion mode right
which is yeah a whole difficulty level
so pretty much the equivalent of what
Nick but back to the mouth came out with
a DLC for hard mode right so the amiibo
from our understanding is bringing a
locked fusion mode which is their hard
mode that you can only unlock
by having this amoeba so wait a minute
wait wait a minute you did not just say
that they have an amiibo of DLC on it
direct this all right let it says the
deuce machine Metroid amiibo will not
only reveal the location of me but
nearby Metroid on your map when you beat
the game it will also unlock a new
fusion difficulty mode where Samus has
her suit from Metroid Fusion
now the Nintendo has got try to get in
front of it and say because people
whenever arms they like hey this hard
mode is only available do this amiibo
now Nintendo has come out with a
statement they say there is a hard mode
that will not be Meebo necessary but
fusion mode which is I believe is a
harder difficulty and gives you that
suit is locked behind the amoeba
so pretty much we're saying how genius
Nintendo is it's a it's a luck it's
lockable content this ain't grandpa
Nintendo this is that light that uncle
that's a gambler Nintendo they first of
all they roll back on this this is them
trying to fix that because initially it
was hard mode is locked behind it was a
normal mode easy mode and flat out hard
mode was locked behind the amiibo when
they saw everybody get up in an uproar
they said no hard regular hard mode is
fine
so they named the fusion mode and they
renamed something they made it just even
harder than hard mode that's all of this
because because the because of the
uproar when they first mentioned it so
pretty much how it's gonna be is the
original hard mode you get hit once you
die fusion mode you get you step on a
rock you die they just made it more
unforgiving that's all they did because
they the uproar when they first
announced that people flipped out and
they decided to at least retcon out a
little bit and fix that um in terms of
the suit the suit I mean we've seen it
with other amiibo where you get
and people like amiibo I mean we both
sell amiibo is the only sort of games to
life stuff there's still kind of sells
everything else is basically dead on
because they never tried to use amiibo
as games as long as you give me you know
whatever physical content or aesthetic
stuff it's not affecting gameplay but
this stuff is not good any time I don't
care what mode it is it's a super
difficult mode that nobody's really
gonna play or you gonna play five
minutes and you're gonna figure out that
you don't want to play anymore fine but
don't ever lock that behind a physical
purchase give me I don't mind I don't
mind buying something physically and you
give me and you give me a suit or
something like that but the gameplay
elements and stuff like that no no Lord
brap yeah I don't agree with that - that
don't like gameplay content behind toys
you know that's it's not like if I don't
want an amiibo why'd you make me look I
I'd be okay if they gave us the option
if you buy them evil you get this you
know you get the gameplay content - but
if you don't want to bother the amiibo
you can you buy the gameplay content
separate honor you know the only east or
whatever that I'd be okay with that but
to lock it behind it solely that I I'm
not interested in buying it's gonna be
hard to get to and they're gonna have to
go on eBay pay like double the price you
know yeah whoever sits the uncle
Nintendo is right because this is slick
on the tennis yeah it's just the fact
you should never be paying for any of
that stuff I mean if you look at if we
just finished talking about splatoon and
arms and and all the stuff they give you
and then like you didn't gonna like a
hard mode behind something you gotta
purchase oh he's like come on man really
like entire games behind me but what
about the auger in the Lord kick is if
you want that preview experience you
have two people that live that life more
King paving the road for foolishness go
to the week after yeah real quick funny
story like I didn't know anything I'm
just getting back into tendon with the
switch you know kind of getting myself
used to the ecosystem and breath to the
wild comes out you know and I'm checking
my facebook off my friends Facebook feed
all these like exotic looking I'm like
I'm in my feelings because I'm like look
so much better
where did you get that oh what's that
and he shot me like that gives you these
items in game
I'm like okay that must confess look I
had to have that Wolfman around with
three hearts and it was very hard for me
and I'm like wow and not only do these
things do that they give you like daily
on through cooking meals and and weapons
sometimes someone's giving shoes um and
it's a daily thing you just you know and
it goes in and I just thought wow they
are genius this thing as much as I it is
kind of it I gave it they are locking
behind this toy like that is hilarious
to me Lord King the floor is yours
several amiibos I might add fantastic
that they give you things for your
purchase sometimes you buy these little
statues these little toys as
commemorative items of an era of
Nintendo but Nintendo has found out a
way to make you use these toys we're
open we're not taking toys out and
playing with them on the floor that's
not happening I know you sit there with
your little warriors and you visualize
you do it I don't do it but they found a
way for us to take them off the shelves
and to actually use them and they got to
the point where I was using literally 20
for me bows and at 24 hours I was
at my television and my kids to tell you
I will sit there I will put every last
amiibo in go to every last best-selling
every item that I wasn't using my army
of amiibos on your table next to your
switch I brought them all from I was
buying a mean was before just for the
aesthetics I got it no it didn't matter
to me but then just proof of the wild oh
they give you stuff even if they have no
association to say title no perhaps the
Nintendo for making the older ones
relevant in the game still I was
surprised man every every amiibo gave
you something and their me Buhl's
that was linked to their title and name
gave you extra so Nintendo I'm kind of
appalled at what they're doing because
it was a choice of minds to go get this
stuff it was a choice but now if I want
the extreme mode I need this amiibo to
get that out if I do if I want this suit
I need this amiibo to get this out so I
won't be able to complete my game 100%
you telling me BC Lord added completed
breath of the wild without any amiibo
use right so this is the contrast of to
gamers one with amiibo use one without
of me will use we both had different
experiences but we both were able to
complete the game
it wasn't no barriers in Lord addicts
wait yes more grinding yeah but you had
fun along the way and if you choose to
fill a hammer Sisley found a way to
monetize nostalgia right now they're
treading on a very fine line when there
later write something a habitual line
crossing
giggle iced-up is right now and I was
lucky to get those amiibos I'm seeing
the prices of the pre-orders the people
are selling them or they're anticipating
the sale of these amiibos at more than
triple the price and that sucks for
little Tommy that wants to get that suit
or you know older J that wants to get
that suit that they have to pay and
issue prices or they have to pay triple
the price
Tendo finessing all kinds of people shut
out the fastback of the chain he's like
but at least look you look better finish
to Zelda that everybody can wrap this
thing up we wait a little longer than
usual but um you shout out to a Batman
that fact we're coming through talking
games or that's bad much love presents
I will to shout you go yeah it's one to
search about it I want you to plug that
up that that channel man thank you
absolutely I just want to say guys you
had you guys have a great podcast I mean
this is a this was a lot of fun
I love the friendly banter back and
forth and great gaming conversation too
so make sure I'm you know I definitely
appreciate it
much appreciate it we just gonna close
this thing up real quick um before we
actually get into our toes all the way
also wanted to I've got to you actually
mentioned the new poll this week and um
it's gonna be going up on the our P
Twitter soon
it's inspired by the co-host Lord addict
so this is what it's gonna be
so with franchises like titanfall Mass
Effect in the soon to be released
puggy that are initially exclusive has
Microsoft dropped the ball by not
backing the money truck up to secure
these franchises or should Microsoft
focus more on developing in-house first
party exclusive games to hit the polls
you gotta rise porkers
[Laughter]
they'll be use Fastback this one big guy
so yeah it's gonna be a hot one man I've
been seeing a lot of banter and I really
want to get the feedback from the
community so once it goes up I'll put it
out there you guys hit that polling rock
this thing and also um you know like
subscribe and all that good stuff but
we're gonna do our outros my co-host
with the Como's Lord addict and glad you
got free from work and got the cobwebs
out the eyes but tell us what's going on
with you in that channel and you know I
don't know like I could have swore
before cuz it was like 11 and I was like
I got an hour no two hours left and then
I woke up at 1:30 definitely you know
subscribe to me on gaming addict to
follow me on Twitter
Lord addict IOP me and a kid smooth
they're doing a dual review sitting on
series now and uh it's my wishes I
haven't we have to review sunset
overdrive next definitely go check that
out but yeah I appreciate everyone in
the comment section be sure to LIKE the
video because that definitely helps and
absolutely you know Lord a song looking
to find people find you and thanks for
that review on held label spectacular
definitely and I look forward to talking
about a new in charter game in two weeks
I'll be talking about in depth about
that when we get down to that point but
yeah thanks Lord Brad for coming through
man really appreciate it everybody in
the chat getting engaged you guys are
hilarious in the chat always they always
late oh yeah guys can find me on xbox
live at BX on PSN be a sovereign one
word and Louis off IOP on Twitter
absolutely King the premium amiibo
experience game
[Laughter]
bunny bows of a big ass going on his
face thank you for coming through oh man
um like I said I have a couple of your
podcasts that I really want to listen to
so I'm loading them up while they're
loaded up ready from when I had work
tonight so I'm gonna listen to all of
them back to back hit those lights and
stuff like that it was a great
experience for you to come to it felt
really good because all the gamers from
the beginning from the Genesis you got a
chance to watch it it's it was nice to
get that to get that feedback um it was
a beautiful day you can catch me on
Instagram Facebook Twitter tweet me at
King David OTW I'm not going to go into
said basketball game that's supposed to
be played I'm not gonna give any light
to that shadow I'm gonna leave that
there but I'm disappointed just like you
guys so like I said I'm not gonna give
any light to that that'll happen when it
happens
I don't know why this lawyers talking
for this guy again those guys they know
what I'm talking about y'all a be in the
know I will post the pitches and y'all
can watch the stuff on mixer you know
when it goes down we spread a gaming
realness on the IOP and after telling
you what you want to hear but what you
need to shout out again to my brat man
can't say enough about him in the
channel things he does in the community
was a pleasure to have him on the show
and like I said make sure you guys
really support his channel go out there
every Wednesday night it's been for k60
i put his like in the comments you guys
got no
a reason to say you didn't know we're
real in these podcasts
that's what are we all about I think
that's the only time we've ever done
that put I appreciate yeah me definitely
please guys come by every Wednesday
night 9:00 p.m. Eastern Standard Time
and I also do uh rap rants on occasion
too so there's nice those are always fun
just me by myself I'm usually ranting
about gaming related topics or things
that are going on the community so
though I can't wait for when you get on
those amiibos that's gonna be fun what
is please hit that like subscribe I
appeared almost media outlets YouTube
iTunes SoundCloud all that support
really helps the law as much appreciated
we've got some big announcements cooking
up you guys stay tuned things about to
be real hot in these streets but um on
that note we're gonna end this thing
then we out peace